m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en quoi la sécurité informatique
couplé à la concentration de nos données
personnelles est en train de modifier
nos territoires et va encore plus
modifier la conquête de nos territoires
alors dans un environnement entièrement
de digitaliser une tendance à la
digitalisation généraliser la sécurité
informatique est un enjeu important et
mis un peu au coeur de toutes les
problématiques la blocs shane qui a fait
l'objet de nombreuses communications
spécialisée par des grands
informaticiens dans nos nombreuses
d'ailleurs communication tedx mêmes ted
arrivent tous à une conclusion qui est
unanime et la bloque shane est en train
de modifier radicalement notre économie
lamrock shane modifie en profondeur les
modèles économiques
alors les principes d'encryptage sont
pas nouveaux et en oublier utilisez déjà
des messages codés
ils ont crypté leurs lettres de crédit
bien plus tard dans l'histoire enigma
pendant la seconde guerre mondiale
permettra de sécuriser des messages
stratégique puisqu'il s'était des
messages militaire
alors du coup qu'est ce que la blocs
shane amène dans notre environnement qui
finalement doit radicalement changé nos
modèles économiques notre organisation
économique et toute une série d' usage
des plus simples aux plus complexes
alors là blog shane détente
informaticien je vais vous en expliquer
rapidement les principes mais surtout
quelles vont être les incidences le blog
shane c'est un protocole informatique
qui permet de déplacer qui permet de
véhiculer de l'information très très
grande quantité et ce de façon
instantanée est entièrement sécurisé
pour l'instant c'est comme si à chacune
des procédés de traitement dans un
protocole chacun des intervenants de
cette chaîne de traitement
inscrivez sur un feutre indélébile ce
qu'il fait et ce sur un livre dont on ne
peut pas arracher la page
on a la possibilité de transférer cette
information du point a au point b
premières étapes ont réuni en en
capsules des désinformations on les
cryptes on les dates et une fois arrivé
en fait aux poèmes mais on vérifie qu il
y a eu aucune modification
on a donc la possibilité de savoir qu'il
n'y a pas eu d'altération de
l'information alors savoir en crypté un
message militaire pendant la guerre ou
permettre aux templiers de ne pas se
déplacer avec beaucoup d'argent sur eux
en en cryptant leurs lettres de crédit
on en comprend bien en fait à la fois là
la logique et puis la stratégie mais
finalement qu'est ce que le fait de
pouvoir transférer des données en très
grande quantité modifie dans nos usages
les plus quotidiens eh bien ces
modifications sont d'autant plus
importantes que si les données
disponibles stratégiques sont elles en
très grands volumes
imaginez juste un instant dans une pièce
la possibilité de regarder de façon
simultanée
l'ensemble des données financières les
votre pièce d'identité avis d'imposition
fiche de paye relevés de compte
taxe foncière et ce de façon instantanée
une pièce dans lequel tous ces documents
en fait sont répartis et une personne
qui aurait un agrément et votre
autorisation aurez la possibilité de s'y
rendre et d'avoir une vision globale en
instantané de toute votre vie
et bien sachez qu'à ce jour les
informations disponibles sont de plus en
plus importante
les lots de données auxquelles il est
possible d'avoir accès sont de plus en
plus importants et pour une raison déjà
assez simple c'est que l'essentiel de
nos documents en fait sont
dématérialisés alors ces documents qu'on
croyait être originaux patravi
d'imposition votre fiche de paye en
réalité ne sont qu la représentation
graphique d'une base de données
existante votre taxe foncière n'est que
la projection d'une base de données
votre relevé de compte avec le logo de
votre banque votre nom votre adresse
dans l'ensemble des opérations n'est
qu'une représentation en fait d'une
liste d'opérations dans un système et on
a mis plus très loin
alors on va prendre l'exemple des
relevés de comptes dans le cadre de voir
le dit quand il ya encore quelques temps
on consulté notre but comme sur notre
smartphone
c'était bien pratique puisque on peut
regarder au quotidien en fait nos
différentes opérations
il y à peu probablement vous l'avez
remarqué pour certains vous l'utilisez
votre application bancaire vous a donné
l'autorisation la possibilité de pouvoir
rajouter notre relevé de compte celui
d'une autre banque
il existe d'ailleurs les applications
spécialisées ça s'appelle des
agrégateurs qui vous permettent de gérer
votre budget avec qui réunissent en fait
des relevés de comptes de banques
différentes avant pour gérer les comptes
vont à bing bang un compte dans une
banque une cause dans une autre
on les recevait par papiers ont regardé
il fallait qu'on rassemble ensuite on a
eu l'application de la banque alors ce
n'était que les hommes de demain
il fallait regarder les deux
applications il faut avoir les deux
applications du téléphone l'aller les
agrégateurs vous permettent en réalité
de pouvoir mettre vos relevés de compte
tous au même endroit alors si c'est pour
ces pratiques par contre si on se
projette un peu ça signifie qu'avec une
autorisation de votre part on a
rassemblé les informations bancaires
et tout ceci en un seul lieu c'est vous
qui avez décidé de rassembler ces
informations de même mieux dire
concrètement cette technologie elle
existe déjà la procédure existe déjà
c'est à dire votre information
l'information stratégique sensible où
vous avez cliqué vous avez dit oui je
veux rajouter une banque
hop vous avez amis et vous avez vos
banques avec les différentes opérations
qui a dû sur votre sol de global hors ca
distingue même vos consommations
restaurant vos achats
le loyer etc donc effectivement on peut
rassembler de l'information et même
mieux alors s'abaisser uniquement les
relevés de compte comme dirait si vous
avez tous en tête en fait peut-être
votre relevé edf ou votre avis
d'imposition alors lui sont pas au même
endroit ils sont sur des comptes
différents maires je vous propose de
regarder en fait une copie d'écran
il s'agit d'un site du gouvernement qui
s'appelle apis.google.com et me dire
qu'est ce que c'est une api une api
pareil
wass ont le plus souffert possible c'est
une prise
c'est à dire que le gouvernement a mis à
disposition des prises qui permettent à
des gens de venir se connecter
donc sur ce site il y à la liste des api
qui sort aujourd'hui disponibles pour la
plupart certaines qui vont en lettres
permettant à des systèmes informatiques
de pouvoir se connecter pour récupérer
l'information
alors attention il faut une autorisation
naturellement nos clients mais il faut
surtout un agrément tout le monde n'aura
pas accès à l'information en fait des
api du gouvernement il faut pouvoir
respecter un protocole informatique mais
surtout il faut désagréments alors celle
du milieu c'est france connect france
connaît que ça fonctionne déjà
c'est déjà actif il y à des sites à
usages commerciaux qui utilisent déjà
france connect france connect est un
dispositif qui vous permet en fait de
vous identifier
et identifier un utilisateur de façon
formelle avant pour s'identifier on
imagine à la douane
il ya quelques temps on présente une
pièce d'identité et la personne le
douanier ou le policier bain mais terne
et d'équations le document qu'il avait
sous les yeux et regarder si ça
ressemble aimerait où il faut et puis
ensuite bill regardez la photo est un
à l'époque c'était pas comme ça et puis
finalement il dit bon mais c'est bon ça
correspond donc on vous laisse passer la
france connect
c'est à partir en fait d'une comptes
certifiés si vous avez un compte app et
hip hop au point où ameli.fr qui est un
conte de l'état hébreu n'a la
possibilité d' entièrement vous
identifier sans pièce d'identité
on dirait montrer une pièce d'identité
en fait devant votre écran servirait pas
à grand chose mais on est déjà on passe
une deuxième cape
on a vu les relevés de compte qu'on
rassembler et on a vu l'identification
sans aucun contact humaine alors en bas
de page en fait il ya écrit
découvrez les 24 autres api du
gouvernement je vous propose de
parcourir quelques unes
concentrez-vous juste une petite seconde
sur happy du particulier et api
prélèvements sociaux et bien
effectivement sur le site du
gouvernement
si tenté que l'on ait un agrément est
naturellement l'autorisation du client
on a la possibilité de connaître l'avis
d'imposition qui ont des nuages et on a
la possibilité d'avoir une l'équivalent
d'un justificatif de domicile
le montant de la caf que vous percevez
si vous apercevez le coût de votre
embauche le salaire net
le salaire brut et le plus surprenant
généralement c'est la fiche de paye
c'est à dire que dans le cadre de cet
environnement là on a la possibilité
d'identifier quelqu'un on peut par
l'exemple précédent rassembler les
relevés de compte et on a l'ensemble des
données disponibles les vôtres les
miennes
qu'ils le sont avec votre autorisation
dès lors que la personne à l'agrément on
il sur le site du gouvernement et c'est
pas de la science fiction tout à l'heure
l'image faisait référence dans science
fiction là on est réellement dans la
réalité alors toutes ces pays sont pas
complètement déployé mais très
clairement le sont dans la liste des api
qui vont l'être et on rentre dans cet
environnement là alors vous allez me
dire
bon ok il ya de l'information qui est
centralisé on peux m'identifier
ça permet quand même de gagner du temps
c'est intéressant de pouvoir gérer son
budget sur une même application et mais
au final qu'est ce que ça change et ça
change tout je vais vous donner juste un
exemple
à quand la souscription d'un prêt
immobilier en temps réel instantané
juste une incidence qu'elle va devenir
le rôle de mon conseiller bancaire ou va
être bon conseiller bancaire ou va être
l' agence dans lequel il y à mon
conseiller bancaire actuellement
la possibilité de récupérer les données
d'un client financière donc de
solvabilité
d'identité modifie radicalement
l'ensemble des contraintes géographiques
et temporelles de la souscription d'un
crédit
alors on a tous un exemple où ça vous
est arrivé où vous avez un ami à qui
c'est arrivé qui pour acheter un bien
immobilier
on leur a demandé une ramette de papier
ce véhicule à trois quatre rendez-vous à
la banque 2 3 mois pour pouvoir réaliser
l'opération
là il ya plus de documents plus de
documents l'instantanéité de
l'information
on a transfert de l'information sécurisé
on a une décision normés et instantané
cela modifie radicalement le territoire
de l' agence bancaire
cela modifie radicalement son maillage
cela modifie radicalement la stratégie
pour acquérir des clients pour rentrer
en contact avec son client
c'est une époque où on allait déposer
les étrennes en fait au guichet à vous
avez pas un projet dans l'année oui ça
crée un lien là
finalement la sécurité informatique la
disponibilité des données engendre des
modifications qui vont bien au delà
elles ont bien au delà parce que ça fait
évoluer la notion de proximité
la proximité qui était une notion
purement géographique être côte à côte
devient une notion qui est technologique
c'est à dire être connecté être proche
des zones d autres
être proche de son client être proche de
sa famille n'est plus le client alors ça
ne modifie pas que ça ça modifie aussi
les notions de centralité
c'est à dire que avant être au centre
c'était être accessible géographiquement
là encore maintenant une territoire
central peut se voir être mis en
concurrence par une territoire qui se
risquent sur connecter cela modifie la
relation que l'on a à la centralité et
rares sont les phases dans l'histoire
dans lequel des centralités ont bougé et
on est très clairement en train dans mon
livre une alors il ne s'agit pas de
porter le jugement sûr est ce que c'est
bien ou est-ce que c'est pas bien
par contre c'est enclenché un essai le
sens de l'histoire
il s'agit pas non plus la de minimiser
les impacts sociaux que cela peut avoir
et que cela va et que cela va avoir
on a bien vu dans l'exemple bancaire le
monde bancaire est en train de
radicalement évolué et changé
et du coup le personnel bancaire il ya
une redistribution complète en fait des
missions et des territoires
dans ce domaine là mais on pour on
aurait pu prendre néanmoins notre
exemple parallèlement et là ça va être
plutôt pour ma nature ça ouvre aussi des
opportunités on a parlé de
redistribution de centralité on a parlé
d'être compétitif de se remettre
en fait dans une vie
lilith est possible par contre
clairement on n'est plus dans un
environnement où c'est la distance qui
va jouer un rôle
la position de centrale devient en fait
une notion connectés et dans lequel la
proximité toutes les règles de proximité
ont complètement changé la sueur
connexion est une opportunité
territoriales il faut en prendre la
grande mesure parce que au final cet
objet que l'on a considéré dans un
premier temps comme étant futile inutile
et le vecteur de la révolution
industrielle qui est en cours et cet
objet détrompez vous ce n'est pas un
téléphone c'est un véhicule à très
grande vitesse
merci
[Applaudissements]